[Music]
look what I become
[Music]
all right we got a special podcast here
for you today with the Amanda myth the
legend Kurt Schilling uh if you don't
know who this man is let me kind of
share with you his resume and then what
else you know some other things we can
talk about him uh but first things first
um 2001 World Series MVP with the
Diamondbacks he won the World Series
again in 2004 with the Red Sox the the
big one where they came back and they
beat the Yankees which if you've seen
the captain you're in the captain twice
by the way
with the Red Sox then again 2007 World
Series uh when you look at his resume
there's only two players in the history
of baseball who have 3 000 strikeouts
not on the Hall of Fame it's himself uh
and Roger Clemens is the other one one
of them is obviously not in it for
steroids this one it's because of other
reasons which we'll definitely get into
today uh what else can I tell you record
for uh most strikeouts in a single
season as a right-handed pitcher for the
national league uh the record that he
said three seasons with 20 plus wins
he's in the Boston Red Sox Hall of Fame
he's in the Phillies Wall of Fame he's
just not in the Hall of Fame because out
of the what 399 writers that get to vote
whatever the number is uh just like most
professors in America that for every one
conservative Professor 13 hour liberals
most of the these writers are on a side
that don't agree with his political
leanings and this is being said by a lot
of different players even Bob Costas who
doesn't agree with Kurt Schilling's a
politics said you belong in the Hall of
Fame because of what you did when you
played uh in the field so having said
that with that being said Kurt thank you
so much for being against an honor it's
a privilege I'm a fan I I've become a
fan uh I've in my life doing the things
that I did I always thought the best got
to look for study research advice and
you know you're somebody who's first of
all your story is amazing thank you for
your service uh and you're uh 101st
Airborne my dad was Hunter first
Airborne so I felt an imperative to to
show up and be on this one it's crazy
you were to thank you for that and thank
you for your dad service you were
talking about how your dream was to go
in the military well 13 years old uh
living in Arizona my dad had recently
retired and um
I went out to our garage in Arizona and
his rucksack was there
and I opened it up and his jump boots
were in it and they were freshly
polished and this was five years after
he had left the service
and my first thought was I want to do
something that instills that much pride
in what you do my dad was still
polishing his jump boots five years
after he was out that and that resonated
with me and stuck with me forever and
I don't know fortunately I guess I
learned how to throw a round ball kind
of hard and accurately not a pace well
yeah it's okay it did all right yeah you
know how to throw a picture I I saw uh
career earnings today you'd be one of
those 300 million dollar picture type of
guys but still career earnings even when
you pitch you you made 110 150 million
bucks you made good amount of money I
made a lot of money uh unfortunately 38
Studios happened the the software
company and a lot I was
I don't know uh I was at the helm of
that one and I put a lot of my money
into that and lost a lot of my money
there but we're doing all right my my
you know I don't have to work I'm
retired my Mondays and Saturdays are the
same so that's not a bad thing but uh
yeah I mean it paid and and I promised
myself I'd never be that guy like
gosh if I made what they made today you
know but I look at it now and I'm
thinking to myself I see these one-year
30 million dollar deals and I'm thinking
to myself wow Charles Barkley talks
about that a lot basically how these
cupcakes are making 100 million in the
NBA they're no neighbors you know who
was the first one that got a weird
contract where I'm like serious and
remember Sports basketball basketball
basketball was a guy from uh uh Seattle
Seahawks the one guy that got a
six-year-old Seattle supersonic Seattle
SuperSonics not Sean Kemp no Sean Kemp
was a player are you talking about
deadlift shrimp no it was another guy
he had a good shot three he averaged 19
points again he got 120 million then
Connolly uh uh Mike Connolly Mike
Connolly from Memphis or something got
150 million dollars 140 million dollars
I'm like yeah they have me in the
bathroom no choice now you don't even
need to be an All-Star in the NBA to get
100 million you don't have to be
anything you could be an everyday a
backup pool pool exactly that's what I'm
thinking of it just gotta get punched up
by Draymond Green your butt three years
from Miami uh oh Duncan Robinson not
Duncan Robinson yeah
you only need one general manager to
cross the line it's like uh was it the
Rangers gave Channel Park everyone then
there's always that one the handheld
Park contract after the chanho park
contract I looked at that and I said he
should be forced to actually based on
his performance to pay a tax to actually
play baseball I remember I was a
pleasure crazy man the lockout 94 I
remember all the owners talking about
trying to keep each other reined in and
you're talking about 30 billionaires you
know it's not going to happen and
they're talking about fiscal sanity and
and I take keep keep trying to explain
to the fans you understand the owners
are trying to tell us to tell them how
much they can spend on us there's no
logic to this and sure enough during the
lockout when they're talking about
salaries and contracts Jerry weinstraff
goes out and signs Albert Bell to some
monster contract and Jerry can't sit in
the room and look across the table this
is Albertville like Joey Bill Cleveland
yeah Albert Bell was a beast oh he
something happened he threw the ball at
the fence or he did something he got
suspended for he he got suspended a
couple yeah yeah he was he went up here
for second baseman he ran through
Pennsylvania yeah yeah so so you know a
lot of times people you know the
conversation comes up and you know why
certain people are not in the Hall of
Fame you've been asked this many times
you've been on the Conan O'Brien I think
it was Conan O'Brien show where he asked
you about hey do these guys belong etc
etc and uh it always comes up with bonds
do you put the Astrid do you put all
this stuff I saw this picture I want to
share with you how much of this picture
hurts you getting into the Hall of Fame
well I mean if you look at it's a
10-year cycle yeah you go on five years
after you retire and you're on the
ballot for 10 years and and for me I've
always been asked if I was the Hall of
Fame I wouldn't be in my hall of fame
because to me the Hall of Fame is I say
a name and you say yes or if you pause
then it's a no you know so I'm an I'm a
I'm a guarantee you know if I say Mario
novare you say yes
it rains closer of all time right and if
I say somebody like Andy Pettit you're
gonna sit and think for a minute right
anybody you have to think about to me
shouldn't be in the Hall of Fame so I'm
not in mine and I'm okay with that but
when you look at the vote totals over 10
years I I never won a game or struck out
of the hitter after I retired my vote
totals change yearly
and that to me that was always you know
one and done for me would have been fine
for from and after about five years the
process became so painful at home that I
just dreaded every the year the time of
the year coming around because of the
things that were said and you know I
think it goes but what I know it started
the the day we wanted to know four the
day after we won an o4 86 year curse and
all the stuff that goes with it I was on
Good Morning America with the Red Sox or
something yeah and I was I was one of
the Disney guys you know I was I after
the game I said hey we're going Pedro
and and David and I were the Disney guys
so meaning hey you just won the World
Series where you're going so we're going
to Disney right thanks Kurt Schilling so
on WE flew back from St Louis and and it
was just an unbelievable morning and I
was doing good morning America Charles
Gibson at the end it was right around
the election
in 2004 and I said hey at the end of the
election at the end of the show I said
to Charles Gibson I said hey make sure
you tell everybody go out and vote and
vote Bush well I didn't think right I'm
in New England you know Don Kerry grew
up five minutes
and Charles Gibson's looking at me and
there's like a 10 second pregnant pause
of nobody said anything and I'm like
this is awkward and he's like yo okay
and after that it just went nuts I got a
call from President Bush like 20 minutes
later hey I want you to come campaign
with me and button the Red Sox went nuts
they were like we don't want you to do
this and and we don't want you to get
involved and then they started flying
John Kerry around on the owner's private
jet when I was so it started then and
our Charities suffered and we lost tens
of millions of dollars uh we were we've
worked with ALS for almost 30 years
and uh my wife's uh melanoma Foundation
lost sponsorships and all the things go
with that and
it just steamrolled um and that was the
beginning the beginning of the end for
me was and if I think if you and I I've
researched this so I'm comfortable
saying this I believe that I was kind of
Ground Zero of the cancel movement I was
the first guy to really get canceled for
doing nothing I compared Islamic
extremists to Nazis which historically
is factually perfectly correct I said
men should use the men's room and
women's use the women's room uh I said
Hillary Clinton shouldn't just be in
jail she should be under a jail
somewhere which she still should be
um and then I uh commented on a picture
of trans trans bathroom law and that was
the one that ended up being the one that
ESP inspired me for out of all of those
that's the one that got ESPN yeah yeah
and I I I would like to think it was
because I was really really good at what
I did that they kind of held back and
held back but but it was the it was the
weirdest working environment I mean I
can't tell you how many hundreds of
hundreds and I said I mean hundreds of
people the ESPN will come up and say it
was like Hey I'm with you politically I
can't say anything but I'm with you I'm
with and it was just really awkward and
uncomfortable you know it's crazy when I
was there interviewing Stephen A Smith
okay and we were I was with Ray dalio
and then afterwards we contacted him and
say come on by let's do it in New York
so uh I go sit down I'm here getting
ready to talk to Stephen A and we want
to talk politics and sports right
and you see one of his guys handlers
comes up Say pat look we follow your
content we know what you're doing just
please don't talk politics that's what
he wants to talk about right you can't
talk politics I said that's what he
wants to you can't talk probably you
can't talk politics you can't talk
politics he says if you talk politics
producer saying you can't do the
interview anyways long story short what
do we talk about sports right so they're
standing right there while I'm doing the
interview and every time you get close
to they would come behind the camera and
signal and uh and then just recently
Stephen Stephen launched a podcast I
don't know if you saw that or not and
the first guest he had on was Chris
Cuomo you know who his second guess was
Sean Hannah was a second guess and it
was on Fox uh being interviewed by
Waters and Waters said am I your
favorite host on Fox that says no my
good friend Sean Hannity so I kind of
like where he's going obviously he's
still gonna play to the ESPN but the
fact that he's even talking about it
that's some progress I think we're
starting to see that with a lot of hard
left I I went out on Stephen A Smith
when and uh in the walk when Washington
Robert Griffin was in Washington and he
was benched because he sucked and and uh
Stephen A tried to make it a a debate
about color and it wasn't and he did
that he did that I've heard nothing but
great things of people that have met
Stephen I don't really know him I think
he really get to know him but now
imagine imagine me at ESPN and I'm very
comfortable being who I am and saying
the things I say can you imagine what
the producers were like every night for
baseball tonight worried about a comment
because you know and oh my God we and we
used to have fun in the green room I
would talk to the guys and once the
Trump announced he was running I said
listen guys take the under and they're
like what are you talking about I said
the over under on me being fired by
March of next year is I would take the
under because if Trump's running there's
going to be problems and I'm not going
to be I'm not going to have an issue
talking and saying how I feel about
things and people are going to have a
big problem when you started saying
stuff about Trump did that cause
anything at first or they were okay with
that well I was never I I mean I was
never
blatant well you and you know this as
well as anybody the things that are said
and done are very uh there's a Chasm
between those things and what people
report was said and done right I mean
well for example I'll give you a great
example uh I have been in the world war
the board of directors uh of the World
War II Museum in New Orleans
um I helped put the Richard Winters
statue over in brickwork Manor in in
France and then World War II military
history has always been a passion of
mine clearly grew up a flag waving
Patriot my dad was my whole family
served in all different branches and I
have a very large collection of World
War II memorabilia and
I'm dumb and I'm naive in the sense that
I I believe in the inherent good in
people and I had a young lady from the
Boston Globe asked to come out and do a
story about my collection I was like
great that's awesome I have General
Bernard Montgomery's beret the one you
see him in in pictures I have that and
I'll have the iconic wow yes and I have
all the corresponding I have all these
things I have stuff from Patton
everything and she came out and she she
left and did the story and the story
came out and it was a picture of uh some
uh German uniforms and it said Kurt
Schilling's Nazi memorabilia collection
that's what the title that was the story
the entire story was about that and I
was just flabbergast I was crushed again
I'm what year is this this was probably
less than 10 years ago this was during
the Hall of Fame stuff and so you know I
I and I got to see it firsthand as a 86
of the sports media is reportedly
liberal hard leaning left I would tell
you that probably the same majority of
athletes are are right center right
because as an athlete you don't get
handed anything you have to I mean as
much as people like to think you've been
given athletes are some of the hardest
working human beings there's no question
about it and and especially if you have
to be a captain well it's not it's also
the opposite of what I thought I came to
the big leagues and Cal Ripken was my
first shortstop in the big leagues and I
just assumed you know this guy's just
gifted well Cal Ripken worked harder
than any shortstop I ever played with
from that day forward it kind of spoiled
me on shortstops and ruined my image
because everyone I played with after
that I'm thinking to myself you're not
Cal Ripken why are you not working
harder and Barry Bond same way work
ethic Manny Ramirez was one of the
hardest working players I ever Manny
oh so you have to understand the life
when we travel uh you know it's a it's a
it's a tough travel and I say tough in
the context of playing sports every
morning at 10 A.M on the road Manny was
in the hotel lobby with the weight coach
went to lift and then went to the park
and hit it noon every single day
that takes immense amount of work ethic
but discipline and I found that to be a
common thing and I'm sure that you'll
relate to this
every great player I and every per and I
studied I Dr Ben Carson one of the best
brain surgeons in the in the world and
and tennis players and baseball players
and and any profession I was always
looking for the best because I wanted to
find out I didn't want to reinvent the
wheel I wanted to see if I could find
shortcuts
and the one thing I found was everybody
that's great at everything there was an
insane attention to detail the minutia
that's what well and you start thinking
about it you have two and a half hours
of game time every night which is equal
amongst all of your peers there's 21 and
a half hours of day left what do you do
with those that's where the separation
comes because at some point in your life
you step on a stage or you step on a
field where everybody's as good or
better than you for most of the
population that happens in high school
or junior college or college yeah for a
minute percentage it happens in
professional sports and when you step on
that field for the first time and
everybody this is good or better than
you how do you react
and that to me was watching how they
reacted and talking every guy that was
living in the Hall of Fame that Siever
Gibson fell or kofax Ryan Drysdale uh
Tony all of them I spoke to all that I
talked I I dug because I wanted to know
what makes them tick and and I learned
as much from Tony Gwynn and Manny
Ramirez about pitching as I did from any
pitcher just because of talking to the
best of the best at what they do Manny
Ramirez that just gave a completely
different perspective probably the one
of the two smartest offensive players
ever played who would you put ahead of
him him and Lenny Dykstra Lenny Dykstra
mentally offensively as talented Lenny
Dexter and Manny Ramirez were the two
guys in my life that I play with who
multiple times told me what was going to
happen and in a bat before it happened
and it happened exactly the way they
said it was going do you remember the
story that um Billy Bean told about
Lenny Dykstra which one you interviewed
yeah you know Billy Bean obviously he
told multiple stories he says uh one
story member he said is like why are you
reading you know that's bad for your
eyes it's going to help you you need
your eyes for for hitting you know to
see but he's like why am I reading what
do you mean but Lenny Dexter was that
focused and hitting not reading he was a
beast artist listen career whatever he
did business I'm not even talking about
that yeah well and I gotta tell you I'm
I'm still I still speak with him every
now and then
um the off the field stuff was crushing
to me because it was it was horrible it
was it he was a degenerate and he'd
probably be the first to admit that he's
just completely screwed his life but on
the field
so we're playing in game five game five
of the playoffs in 93 against the brave
it's extra this is
what you're doing from the Mets right
right and they tied it up in the ninth
inning Lenny tells me
he said and uh okay I'll tell you the
whole so Lenny had a lisp all right and
this is Lynn so this is when he talking
he's like hey bro this is what's gonna
happen bro right here I'm telling you
right now bro this is what's gonna
happen
well Mark Waller's is pitching he said
this dude's gonna work I'm gonna work
this count against this dude and we're
gonna get it full I'm gonna get a Full
Count he's gonna try and throw me a high
fastball
I'm going yard
watch it back he tells you this works to
count full High fastball homerun to
center field and he's running around
third base in slow-mo so you can hear
him he's screaming didn't I didn't I and
he did things like it but mentally he he
was born some people are born to do
things he was born to play base that you
guys also had Darren Dalton right who
was like one of the best catchers in the
league at the time so when I my and I
I'll tell long-winded stories to get to
the point but when I was in uh my first
trip in the Middle East I was at the the
headquarters of the fourth ID the day
three men got lost three men lost their
lives on patrol and they came back and
informed the the fourth ID major Hammond
I think it was his name at the time
he addressed the room and it was one of
the most powerful five minutes of my
watching him address his soldiers
uh I'd never seen I never felt you could
feel it right I mean it's just that
sense of leader some people were just
born to lead and this guy clearly had
everything about him was lit that was
Darren Dalton the best leader of people
in any venue I've ever been around in
one way and was never said the wrong
thing at the wrong time and always said
the right thing at the right time wow
and he knew his and this is what a
leader is Right a leader is the person
who puts his position in the best people
in the best position to succeed I don't
care what you do for a living right you
understand your roster you understand
who's what strengths are and what
weaknesses are and you put those people
accordingly Darren knew us to the point
where Philadelphia northeast media could
be a little bit of an animal right you
can play the game and then you have to
play the media game afterwards Darren
and I'll give you a quick example middle
of the Season I'm struggling having the
worst month of my career and it's all
self-inflicted and we just get I I pitch
a game in St Louis and I give up like
505 runs in two innings it was it was
horrific and it's 190 degrees out on the
turf there and after the game
we had another picture on our staff who
was really really good but but mentally
wasn't a strong guy
Darren goes to the media comes to Darren
he says you know he calls me out he said
you know what this guy's worried about
all the wrong stuff doing all it and
just he's saying to sort of media over
just burying me
and and the other guy he doesn't really
say much about but he hints that it's
more than one guy and the media comes
sprinting over to Philadelphia media
they're in love with this right they
came right over my locker and they lay
out this laundry list of things that
Darren just said about me and they look
at me and they're like
what do you got to say and I was like
he's right
he was and I okay I got called out for
some I had never had a problem listen as
a Christian the one thing I'm telling
you is I'm admitting to you that I'm far
from perfect so I don't have a problem
being wrong I have a problem being wrong
twice but I did I was like yeah he's
right and I knew what he was doing more
importantly so then stupid me says well
you know I'm this and that I'm not going
to lose the game the second half and I
didn't but the point was I was I was
really you're losing no no I was that
guy well you said this to who though
you're not going to lose again the media
you told him you're not gonna You're
Gonna Lose I did that a lot though
because well and but because a lot of it
sometimes nothing out there will put the
challenge to you that you put to
yourselves right and I'm okay with that
but by the way the the other picture we
won't talk about his name was he also
protecting him that's why he threw you
on exactly because he knew you could
take it and he couldn't exactly right
and I don't know if this Dynamic happens
in the military but I've had situations
where
as a coach I want to find a player Oh
preferably my star listen I'm going to
undress you in front of the team don't
take it personal I don't mean it to you
but if I can undress you in front of the
team then nobody's exempt right that you
always want that guy and I was I was
comfortable being stuck I was
comfortable being that guy yeah because
I knew who I was but was he a feared guy
or was he a respected guy Dalton so he
was he was a bad so would he push around
because he wasn't he was a big guy he
was not a in 22 years of professional
sports I never was on a team that got in
spring training fights we fought four
times that spring we cleared benches
with us we is who our team cleared
benches with other teams four times
because we finished in last year before
and we were like you guys aren't pushing
us around and we were big bunch of boys
yeah yeah John crock who was leading guy
right Dave Hollins who was the meanest
toughest player I ever played with in my
life Dave Holland Dave Hollins 17 this
guy has an operation broke his handmade
bone he's got a pin sticking out of his
thumb 17 days after the surgery he's in
the batter's box playing in a game with
a pin still sticking out of his hand
who else who else was on that team
you're talking about these two badass
dudes Mitch Williams yeah 23 years of
playing baseball only Battle of pitch
only bad team I never had really only
about that's the only bad Mitch Williams
because he was kind of a loose cannon
pitcher right yeah he was what he was he
had uh the guys that it's it's funny too
because when I think back to the most
impactful guys in the clubhouse setting
and it's one of the Dynamics that and I
say this very Loosely I share with
the military the barracks
Police Barracks the fire Barracks the
sports Clubhouse those are four places
that the real world couldn't function
the things that we say and do to each
other in those environments because I
can say anything I want about your
mother but nobody else can right in that
environment that is the definition of
locker room talk it it's the place where
my God I wish America was because where
you come from what color you are and who
you sleep with are totally irrelevant
can you turn a double play with runners
in scoring position okay as long as
you're not sleeping with my wife I don't
really care who you sleep with I don't
care who you worship or pray yeah those
things are irrelevant and so it's the
most
racially inclusive
Club you'll ever be in and the things
that are said in there if if the real
world knew they would probably stop
watching sports the things that we say
and do to each other in those
environments but it's how you de-stress
because we lose a game but we do it in
front of 50 000 people on TV in front of
hundreds of thousands when you lose in
that environment you lose a life
and there's a very different you know
obviously very good perspective right
there yeah yeah so so Dalton who else
did you play with that was an incredible
captain of the team leader of the team I
played with so so it and I think it
probably mimics real life and I say that
because coming out of professional
sports and going into the software
industry and running a company that was
almost 300 strong I saw
the enormous discrepancies that should
not have been between sports and and I
say that in this way in sports you'll
have guys uh that sixth man in the NBA
um uh you know you'll have that that the
second third line in hockey you'll have
that uh utility guy in baseball all
those guys excel in those roles because
that's what they're meant to do that's
six man if you played every would get
exposed he has a weakness that utility
guy couldn't play 155 games but he's
exceptional playing 75. and I find in
the real world it's a lot like that in
the sense that people get promoted out
of their skill set you find a guy that's
a tremendous producer and you say God
you're so good at this I want you to
manage producers well he's doesn't mean
he's going to be a good manager and you
see that happen a lot example great
players don't make great managers Pete
Rose wasn't a good manager my first
manager in the big leagues Frank
Robinson I would argue the most
underrated player in the history of
baseball was a terrible manager
terrible because
he couldn't understand he's a Hall of
Fame player one of the greatest had ever
lived Frank Robinson couldn't understand
if there's a runner on second just hit a
ground ball to the right side move the
runner over how hard is that well
actually it's kind of hard Frank it's in
the big leagues it's you know but but
guys that are great at stuff sometimes
have trouble understanding how you can't
just do things and I found that people
uh players in the big leagues Doug
Mirabelli I play with Doug and one of my
still one of my best friends backup
catcher Todd Pratt backup catcher in
Philadelphia enormous Clubhouse
influencers
and I found it was for this reason
leadership
is is something I think it's genetic
right
um You can put a c on somebody's Jersey
that doesn't mean they're actually going
to leave who was a real C though um and
the reason why I'm bringing this up
because you did you watch Captain did
you watch all the episodes yeah so you
know the conversation came we were
watching it this last weekend at the
breakers we brought 50 of our Executives
and we watched the whole thing we've
done the same thing with men in the
arena we rented at Foxboro and we watch
it and we did the same thing with the
Last Dance we watched these
types of documentaries and one of the
topics that came up was Jeter won four
out of five as a non-captain but one out
of 15 as a captain which means you know
if you take that as a you know he always
had a squad it's not like he didn't have
players with him still a small sample
size but I understand this it's still a
small sample size so the question then
comes to you know again going back to
you who would you say was a great
captain
I'm when I came up with the Orioles Cal
Ripken was kind of the guy right Calvert
never had a clubhouse mating he didn't
stand up in front of the team and talk
cow uh would go on the field and expect
you to play the game the way he played
the game and if Cal had a problem with
you he'd pull you aside no one touched
Aaron Dalton Darren Dalton was so far
beyond anybody I ever played with as a
leader Jason baretek was was the captain
in Boston he didn't have Clubhouse
meetings same thing I'm gonna show up
and play the game and work this way I
expect you to do the same so it was more
about because to me leadership is two
things one is setting the example for
people to follow number two is getting
people to do things they wouldn't do on
their own leadership is statistically
agnostic in my mind the best leaders I
ever had had nothing Darren Dalton
that's what made him so great
it didn't matter what his batting
average was if there was something he
said he said it and there are a lot of
guys who believe I have to do you know I
was never a leader in the sense I was
always a veteran and I led my pitching
staffs but I was never a clubhouse there
because I didn't play every day I
couldn't tell you what it's like to to
play game seven of the week on a Sunday
Day game when it's 155 in St Louis but I
could pull you aside and talk to you and
tell you and that was what the great
leaders did they knew and same thing
they knew their players there knew he
could call me out so he did and then the
guys he needed to pull aside and take
behind in the back room he did that too
I'll tell you a great story
um a guy that we got you know for
Orlando Cabrera we traded for him he
came over from the Expos I didn't know
him I knew it played against him
um uh we had a guy who a star on the
team uh and you'll you'll probably guess
who he was but he was a Latin player he
didn't dress with the rest of the team
he dressed in the back with the trainers
he did his own thing
one day or right after the trade Orlando
comes over uh and this guy's name is
scratched out of the lineup and now I'm
I'm in the part of the locker room where
this guy dresses and there's hot tubs
then I'm in the hot tub and Orlando
comes back and and this guy looks at
Orlando and says hey Poppy what's up
he's like don't poppy me he's like
what's up he said Your name's not in the
lineup yeah a little tight today he's
like no no no
I'm gonna come back here in 20 minutes
if your name's not back in life you and
I are gonna go
who said this to him Orlando Cabrera
said this to this guy said this to the
to the guy who was a star yeah we're
gonna
fight I'm here to win a championship I
don't give a [ __ ] what this other stuff
is 20 minutes later his name was in the
lineup that's a leader huh back to your
initial comment about sometimes if
you're a great producer you might not be
a great manager right so you know
different qualifications for leaders
like I'm a big NBA guy I mean I know
Major League Baseball as well NFL like
it you know Michael Jordan Larry Bird
right even recently Steve Nash Jason
Kidd these guys haven't never won a
championship never been to a finals
maybe bird maybe one time but never won
anything but meanwhile you've got Steve
Kerr he was a eighth guy on the bench
right you've got uh well even Phil
Jackson and Pat Riley these guys were
never and look at these guys managing
the playoff teams right now you know you
had something Seattle Scott was a backup
catcher kind of yeah I played with Scott
you know he he screened manager as a
player Aaron Boone one of my favorite
human beings in the world not a
superstar that amazing hit yeah but but
I'm saying they didn't have profound
outstanding careers of length Craig
Council I think one of the best managers
in the big leagues Bob Melvin one of my
you know these guys are all and then
there's the you know the Phillies
manager you got guys that none of them
are superstars now they'll bring in the
Superstars as bench coaches or or places
but but being a leader again
to me is statistically agnostic is it
because your skill set doesn't translate
it's just right it's the same thing in
the military you don't have to have the
stripes on your jersey for the guys in
your unit to look to you as a leader
because when the shots start firing
everybody's knocking their heads down
the hole they're looking to one guy and
that General sometimes that's not the
guy with the most stripes on his
shoulder who would you say Kevin milar
was would you say he was a the locker
room guy that rallied or was he he was
just a uh he was uh he was the guy who
who kept it light he kept it light yeah
because in the documentary you know it's
like hey you just got to win one we just
got to win one right well I mean and and
you know that was
that was a very different group of guys
I mean we uh we you know the the a lot
of times when people ask me about the
ankle and the and all the things that
went around that I try to explain to
them
I didn't do anything I didn't think the
other 24 guys would have done were they
in my place and and as as you know it's
it's baseball it's a sport and and I
don't want to go to these extremes but
we would take a bullet for each other in
that sense like you play with certain
you're with each other nine months every
hour of every day you get in I you know
you get in fights we got there were
fights in the clubhouse we had some of
the funniest greatest like fisticuff
brawls ever at 2 30 in the morning out
in front of a hotel on the road because
we were drunk and somebody said
something stupid who was the best
brawler who was like the one that just
straight up was always down and was good
so the guy that well I don't Jason
vertek was a guy that I I so I lock her
next to Jason who loved to be naked and
it was embarrassing because he was you
know he was he had like two percent body
fat and he just sat around like put some
clothes on dude all right catch her
right complete Jason yeah Captain yeah
but but like Dave Hollins was the
toughest player ever played with by a
wide margin they both feared yeah can
you pull him up Tyler Dave Hollins his
nickname was Hedley because his head was
like nine and three quarters
there he is that's a young Dave and by
the way his son yeah look at that head
that's like eight and a half size I just
was with him last week his son uh is
going into his junior in high school
probably gonna be I I would tell you
we'll be the number one pick in the
Major League draft in two years that
could two ways first baseman pitcher
left-handed top of the rotation guy
number four hitter type town so like
like uh oh tiny type of guy yes
unbelievable what are your thoughts on
that guy by the way what he's done in
the in the league no one's ever seen it
right since like Babe Ruth or something
and Aaron judge had a great year but
nobody was more valuable than a time not
him close he won 15 game store I got 200
guys and almost 40 home runs I mean he's
your Ace and he's your cleanup hitter
you should be the highest paid gun
didn't do what he did at the same time
Babe Ruth was never a pitcher hitter
during the season he didn't it
overlapped a little bit but he never did
both at the same time no one's ever even
come close to doing it much less
he could be the best level well it's not
even doing at this level it's the level
at which he's doing it at this level
he's one of the best hitters in the game
and one of the best pitchers in the game
at the same time where would you put him
ranked picture just pitcher he's in the
top ten easily in the top and hit her
what he's absolutely in the top ten is
he a better hit or pitcher
Otani yes
I mean he's on any given day what yeah
not many guys can win 20 games he can
win 20 games not many guys can hit 40
home runs he can do both which what what
is really the market value for someone
if if he if you're you you just said it
these guys are making 30 40 million
annually
he's worth twice that
but and think about what that means to a
team two roster spots used up by one
player it was insane that's a good point
so so it's it that's a that's a great
art who represents him by as a as a
agent do you know somebody that's gonna
make a whole lot of money a Japanese guy
American guy it's an american guy so you
gotta you gotta realize this guy's so
the sale would be 30 million dollars
times two nice guys a 60 million you're
a guy you could you you can't dispute I
could make the argument if I'm
representing him all day long very
comfortable comfortably very comfortable
60 million dollar guy Kurt If he if he
continues this trajectory for the next
five ten years let's say
all-time rankings where do you think he
ends up all time you're saying if he
puts like 10 seasons continue to do 100
games and hits 500 home runs yeah
I mean he's won he's won
commands but again he does he's doing
what they do with the plate
and he's throwing in Cy Young's so
appreciate greatness while it's
happening in front of us and I've said I
still believe and unfortunately he's
been injured I still believe Mike
Trout's the best player anybody alive
will ever see
having said that now watching this guy
there's two and think about how bad that
team is these two guys are are wasting
away in Anaheim when can you imagine if
they were on the Yankees
oh my God
I can't make the playoffs and you know
what's interesting also
Otani at least to the Casual viewer from
the outside really appears to be a
really decent guy
um they both are they're both very very
good guys if I was so Tony and Kershaw
picked me off because I wasn't paying
attention I was putting my gloves on at
the All-Star Game remember we got the
single and then he didn't put on his
running gloves yet and all of a sudden
oh gosh and Kershaw got him and
everybody every player is laughing
because it's like right Clayton you're
not supposed to do that the All-Star
Game first of all yeah it says and and
then I would have destroyed the Dugout
he just went back down and dug out took
it and actually smirked a little bit and
said well I guess this is where I am but
but you know that's just a decent guy
Billy Bean talked about that you know
when you look at picking up players you
know one of the things is like
temperament and character you can't
teach that well you cannot teach the
character that he's got it's what the
saber met so you know you've seen the
influx of sabermetrics and all the
things you know the the ivy league guys
that never played the game and the
baseball guys who hate them and all that
other stuff I since I met Theo Epstein
in the winter of 2003 it's the one thing
I've always
I've always looked at the sabermetrics
guys the frustration for them they can't
quantify chemistry and it bugs them
because I think Theo got a great lesson
that first year I was in o4 he realized
that I can do all the stat whoring and
tracking I want and put the best roster
together but I can't saberometrically
quantify cannabis Street and I need
those guys in my Clubhouse can you ever
no can you Tom can you ever quantify
chemistry on a business team I mean you
that's like the unthinkable now that
that's why it occurs very interesting we
have a a great investor that we've
worked with over the years and he has
said listen it doesn't matter what era
doesn't matter what industry
fifty percent of the sea level guys that
we bring in don't work after a year and
sometimes it's just the intangibles so
it's always the intention when it gets
down to it it's always the intangibles
right I mean you can you can find a
roster of players who are you know Major
League average
and they won't go 81 and 81. why will
they win 95 games and why will it or why
will they win 65
and it's what those guys that bring the
intangibles to the part how powerful and
how influential they are in the
clubhouse look just last night's game
just go to two nights ago you got the
Lakers playing the Golden State Warriors
right the Lakers have
three players that as Superstars Hall of
Famers yeah I mean you got Westbrook you
got Davis you got LeBron going up
against a team that all of them came up
not all of them most of them came up as
rookies they were drafted and you see
the chemistry of what they got versus
the chemistry that the Lakers have they
they can't create that chemistry that's
what makes basketball so hard for me to
watch is that there are there's no team
that should be able to go into court
with the Lakers and beat them if you're
talking about Talent none and it happens
all the time well what's the famous
quote uh culture beat strategy for
breakfast any day of the week so but but
just a couple other topics with with uh
uh you know Sports going on right now
Trevor Bauer so here's a guy that wins a
Cy Young okay and I know you and him
have gone back and forth and so he was
the Cy Young you know he calls it the
Mickey Mouse trophy whatever he calls so
he's also another guy that's a good
troll he knows how to get under people's
skin and he was doing it regularly
and but this guy was a you know
qualified star pitcher you know he was a
great he won the Scion you don't want to
say young luckily and then all of a
sudden the story comes out
and uh you know he can't play he's not
getting paid never gonna play again you
don't think he's ever gonna play again
but is that deserved though no
absolutely not no no he nothing happened
so what do you mean he's never gonna
play you know as well as I do especially
when you're talking about corporations
and images and and a majority of owners
are very liberal people they're not
going to touch him because
Sports has gotten to a very
uncomfortable place the the professional
sports has started to cater to fans who
don't buy tickets
if you think about the fans they're
catering to they're catering to the fans
who will go to their sponsors and
boycott their sponsors not the people
that show up at the Ballpark or the
stadium or the arena or the rink and
there's think about the blowback I mean
first of all
look at the DeSean Watson stuff and how
that's I mean Cleveland I always say you
know we if you're a if you're a
Cleveland Indians fan or you're a Mets
fan or you're a Rangers Fan you can't be
mad at Players right if you're bad for
30 years the roster turns over your
coaching staff changes the only constant
is ownership
and it's it's owners just consistently
suck at things and just the way it is
Daniel Snyder there's a reason the
Redskins are continually bad
you know there's a reason the Cowboys or
the Supreme roster haven't made that
final step when the owner starts the
meddling your phone over who's who's
making that when the ownership starts to
meddle with the if you're going to hire
people to do things let them do it you
know you know that from business right
you hire you bring people in you you
bring in someone to run your HR
department and then you meddle in every
decision that's made that person is not
running your HR department so you're
saying he's done done he'll never put
you think he'll ever pitch again well
again what can he do though as a player
like you know we have a legal system we
have a Justice and what can what can he
do Can you hire lawyers and go what what
can he do
and there's still nothing's gonna happen
and
I sometimes I feel like sometimes I get
asked questions you know the answer you
know the answer in this day and age with
with the way Society is going it's not
going to get better for him things
aren't going to improve suddenly people
are just going to suddenly start saying
well it's in the past I mean there's
there's some things that we don't have
second chances for in any capacity and
that has to be things with children you
know things with with women and abuse
and things we don't give second chances
to people like that and in many cases I
think we know about that but see he was
this was not there was no legal basis
for them to do this other than he
offended Major League Baseball
yeah the district attorney sat on it for
nine months and then didn't file yeah
but but if you if you go to them and
they drop charges I mean correct they
didn't find enough evidence go to the
Cowboys remember the Cowboys when they
always had issues Leon every time
stories would come out well this person
this and that person this and grows this
and you would get LT stories would come
out none of that is even close to what
this is consensual sex he had the girl
comes back for a second time around
right and all the text messages to back
up what all of it all of it and you
still don't think he's gonna ever play
do you
I would think which team would risk it
to sign him which team would be somebody
that would I don't think well and let's
just add to the fact that he's clearly
kind of a dick I mean if you look at the
way his teammates have talked about him
and the things that he'd done I mean he
and I got into it over the fact that he
cut his finger on a drone during the
playoffs and caught any and his response
was well we won the game I was like well
it wasn't about winning the game that
wasn't the thing you taxed your Bullpen
because you were [ __ ] around with a
drone and it cost your team down the
road he's he's a little short-sighted to
see this unbelievably gifted talented
pitcher but I don't think there's any
team that would want the headache but
Kurt all it takes is one like what
happens to mind is like you know in the
80s and 90s in the NFL who was the team
that would sign all the players with
problems the Raiders Al Davis so if you
had a freaking problem you know if
you're the recent Antonio Brown we're
past that that's what I'm saying is
there a team in baseball that's like all
right we'll be the badass team who was
the running back for the the Ravens so
Ray Rice Ray Rice yeah I mean if you
look at some of the stuff but what he
did was astronomically worse I apologize
for using that as a comp that's not
really but if you look at what's
happening now it it's got
at the end of the day that's why people
say oh you played a game for a living no
no baseball is a 10 billion dollar year
business they'll never forget that these
the only thing owners hate more than
than bad press is losing money and this
there's no what's the advantage
to bringing this guy in
he has to win 20 games 25 games with a
sub 2 er8 to be even remotely Break Even
because of the blowback you're going to
be dealing with even if you give him a
veterans minimum this guy who used to
make 30 million here's the problem I
mean you gotta there's gonna be some
value there no problem becomes when you
go to a New York every single start of
Trevor Bauer's season all 25 guys are
being asked what they think about Trevor
Bauer it's an enormous like headache it
is and your teammates have to deal with
it and you know I'm sure I've seen video
he's running around like throwing to
hitters I've never heard of and I think
that's my phone actually I apologize for
that oh I thought I turned it off those
are my chickens bucking but no one wants
to deal with it and I you know I really
don't blame them I I I it's it's brother
just so you know at 30 years old his
country so here's how we got paid he
played for the Diamondbacks for four
years uh for two years he got 1.18 then
he got two years Indians 1.18 then he
went to one one nine they went to 3.5
million with the Indian stand six five
then Thirty million Indians then 17-5
Reds then 31 Dodgers 35 Dodgers he's
supposed to be at 35 obviously he's not
getting paid this is going to cost this
guy oh hundreds a couple of hundred
million dollars and he's at the peak of
his career
peak of his earning potential peak of
the earnings potential ah man this is
this is a very very strange to me uh
when you see the way baseball's played
it so they they let the they let one
section of it play out so that goes from
July to the end of the next season so
there's a year and a half of career
until just now we hand down the two
years so now he's got two years so now
you're out to the end of the 24 season
so effectively that's three and a half
Seasons at 30 to 40 million and so
baseball is drawing a line at three and
a half years and they're just saying
okay I dare you just leaving it in the
hands of the owners right it's like
three and a half years from now three
and a half years from the The Fury that
went with it and by the way I got two
daughters and no one wants to read about
this kind of stuff no none of us do I
said but
my legal brain says you know it was
consensual between two adults and it's
really unfortunate that that it went
this way however baseball's setting it
up yeah three and a half years which
owner would like to cross the line he
clearly doesn't have a lot of common
sense who who which which owners in
baseball are conservative like you know
how you know Jerry Jones is conservative
like you know where he stands you know
where Robert Kraft stands you know how
certain people stand you don't know who
they are there are so there I know some
but but they don't make it public
because again it's not a it's a it's a
loss leader it's going to bring in it's
not going to help your bottom line to be
openly conservative now
why would it not help your bottom line
to be openly conservative because
because of the activism it's the same
argument we use politically we talk
about fans though that's going to show
up but it's not about the fans it's
about it's about the people that aren't
showing up the people that are going to
go and boycott your sponsors right that
you're talking about and now look at the
contracts look at the payrolls TV gen
the revenue is all coming through the
through through video how much of the
decision of him not coming back is a
Manfred how much of the decision is the
owners
I would say probably 95 5. 95 is yeah
yeah I think that's how it yeah
hopefully oh like the commissioner
doesn't want him in the league he's done
bad PR bad publicity there's no upside
can he can he go to Japan today and get
paid a real kind of money no no no no no
nothing to nothing pays the way we no
and I don't know I don't know about that
I don't know if he could go to I don't
know how Japan would I don't know how
they'd handle that because you don't
read about this with Japanese players
you know read about this in the Korean
League or any of that other stuff where
Tom select played him played in a movie
years ago remember that Mr Baseball
I loved it over there I I went over
there on a tour with the team we played
I that that was Heaven that was that's
what I hear that's what I hear from a
lot of different people anyways listen
for for uh uh for a guy Who's Got Talent
who didn't break the law and they're
taking this position if if manfred's
position was different would the owners
also take a different position on it
they might take a bit different because
I don't I'm I I can't see a team
stepping up to do that not in this
environment I know a lot of athletes
that did a lot of things ten times worse
were not good players who still played
and they were forgiven two three years
later yep well I mean we we've the world
has forgiven Pete Rose even if baseball
hasn't I mean Pete Rose bet on his team
to win and lose as a player to manager
it's a it's a rough thing to you you
know to replace a 35 40 million dollar
your job there's not a lot of places you
can make 35 to 40 million yeah that's
your skills yeah I have a quick question
um regarding Trevor Bauer Japan you
brought up stories about uh you know
Latino guys
um you're an american guy red blooded
American
um if you could rank the best
nationalities in baseball today I feel
like there's so many Latinos yeah okay
there's not a lot of black guys okay
there's a lot of American guys Japanese
guys obviously there's I'm sure more
Americans in MLB but
you know Latin players Latin players
seem to be dominating what's the what's
the breakdown and I don't know what the
breakdown is but to me that's the per
capita there's I mean if you look at
Latino population of baseball I'm gonna
guess it's somewhere in the 20
neighborhood maybe right um but I would
argue that like 85 to 90 percent of them
are above average players right
you don't have the the there's very few
uh Dominican players that are 25th guy
on the roster
um and and having been over there and
and played winterball over there you
understand why I mean the the abject
poverty is I don't think people
understand just how bad it is in those
third world countries and
in the Dominican I I guess I don't know
what to compare it to but baseball is is
your your ticket out period there's no
other ticket off the island same with
Cuba by the way because I can remember
Vladimir Guerrero uh who swung at every
pitch he ever saw in the big leagues
um and a lot of Latin players would say
you don't walk off the island
and and that you know they come over
here his son same way very aggressive
but I mean and then you realize the
environment they grow up in playing in
baseball is life from time they're six
or seven till they're they can't play
anymore it's it's literally a religion
over there and they play in some of the
worst environments as they come over
here
somebody made a very interesting comment
right now they said if Pete Rose put on
a dress and use pronouns he would be in
the Hall of Fame today really quickly if
I may I want to go back to this Trevor
Bauer thing I think this is a really
interesting topic because this isn't the
first time you've seen this right this
is the most dramatic but you've seen it
with DeSean Watson Ezekiel Elliott like
all players in the NFL they mentally you
are guilty until proven innocent and I
think you made a various two point that
it's the people that don't buy tickets
that are coming after or look at
Gillette the the title sponsor the Home
Run Derby right so world we live in now
exactly so do you think it's incumbent
on the GM's and the owners and the uh
the Rob manfreds of the world and the
Roger goodells to step up and say no you
people go kick rocks these people
they're not guilty there's no criminal
charges they did a stupid thing you know
Trevor Bauer he's probably an idiot
there's no criminal charges go away like
he's going to continue to play he's
going to continue to make 100 million
dollars a year he's going to continue to
pitch at the top level kick right that
would be the only way he gets a uniform
on again but it's not going to happen so
I guess my question is are the owners
and the GM's and the uh the
Commissioners feeding into this nonsense
they're cowards that's my problem so is
it incumbent on them to step up and say
you people are ridiculous we're not
friends with what you're after right I
mean again it's a 10 billion dollar your
business they're not going to do
anything that takes money away from that
bottom line
just think about what they did last year
at the All-Star Game right supposed to
be aware the game is supposed to be
playing Atlanta yeah Atlanta and all of
a sudden because of the position that
they had they moved it out so I can't
see what he's saying but uh I don't know
man I mean you go you know Michael
Jordan you know the whole thing with
last stance he says fans don't come here
to watch the GM play fans don't come
here to watch the owners play fans come
here to watch the players play no one's
watching the GM's place so this guy you
know for whatever he was however
controversial he was you know he was
loud he was you know I don't think he
deserves what he's got yeah but in this
day and age everybody else does I mean
listen look no further than Justice
Kavanaugh right guilty until proven
innocent never had a chance yeah didn't
do anything I mean it's just it's we're
in an upside down world man well Kurt
let me ask you just to kind of give a
devil's advocate here and I'm not this
is not a Trevor Bauer thing but like you
see NFL players as an example get a DUI
on the weekend it's like you're making
10 million dollars a year you [ __ ]
idiot why are you driving well drunk I
think like at what point does individual
responsibility come into play here I
think you have to stop
ex stop the expectations first of all
professional athletes there's just as
many spousal abusers drunk drivers and
drug addicts playing in the big leagues
in the NFL than there is working for
Fidelity it doesn't that their income
doesn't change decision making but
shouldn't it if someone's making 10
million dollars a year you should have
people around you save me from myself
how in the world has anybody ever been
convicted of drunk driving in the last
10 years given the the Uber live
everything it's crazy every personal
drivers what are you talking about here
guys that are making 40 million that's
my point but it's common sense and
Common Sense has nothing to do with your
pay with your annual pay nothing
it should give you an acute awareness of
like hey I've got this window well from
20 to 30 to make a hundred million
dollars and whoever's around me needs to
be implementing a strategy yesterday so
I don't screw it up I saw something
yesterday talking about uh celebrities
and why in the world do we think Brad
Pitt's opinion on climate change is any
more valid or even remotely as valid is
somebody who's actually studied it and
it's because of the world his he's put
on a screen he's made to look to be
something he isn't and he's made to talk
in a way he doesn't and we all admire we
think that translates that my ability to
throw a baseball had nothing to do with
my opinion on the the Middle East and
and the conflicts in the Middle East I
mean and I'm I'm just as comfortable
sitting talking about you know uh uh our
insane uh uh you know Fuel and energy
policies as I am talking about pitching
with a runner on third base not
everybody is and not everybody should
mm-hmm so so then this takes me to a
different place though so when you have
this going on with Manfred you're saying
95 95 is Manfred five percent is the
owners not getting it out of my opinion
but yeah of course but Bauer not getting
a job costing them 40 million plus per
year uh how about the way he handled the
the Astros when they won the World
Series
well I mean listen uh they they cheated
in a way that that was uh different than
everything I mean you know everybody
says very creative the way they cheated
absolutely uh and and you know having
played with Alex Cora and and no I I
love Alex I've always loved Alex
um what they did was but but I gotta
tell you I've always said pictures of
the smartest athletes on the field I I
can't imagine uh saying that anymore
given the fact that if they're banging
the garbage can and I'm standing on the
mountain I'm hearing it
and I'm gonna put together the fact that
I just threw a nasty split and some guy
didn't chase it in a one-two count over
and over and over again and you know I I
remember uh the White Sox did it when
they moved into their new stadium before
this last one they had lights on the
scoreboard in the bottom right and
bottom left bottom right was breaking
ball bottom left was fastball and I saw
that like the first series we were in
there
and Jack McDowell talked about it a
couple years back like he said we were
doing for 10 15 years we were cheating
like you know and then you have Spygate
in the NFL with the pain it's a plate
case it's not a game it's a 10 billion
dollar a year business people are gonna
if life hasn't showed us anything it's
that human beings will do whatever it
takes Lance Armstrong to win
because the the thought and and baseball
especially you saw guys still getting
50 60 80 100 million dollar contracts
after being caught cheating with Peds
and so I mean so you're not saying it's
okay you're saying it's what's going to
happen because it's a 10 billion dollar
business is that what you're saying
absolutely okay got it so you're not
surprised it happened no no how how
should have Manfred handled it
because the way it was handled it was it
was a very you know I'm not sure there
were a lot of options in the Senate what
do you do take away the title and give
it to to the Dodgers
do you you do not put an asterisk next
to Doug remember that one player from
Milwaukee Brewers got the MVP and it was
supposed to be careful and all that
stuff and destroyed the life of an
innocent FedEx driver right well and
that you know that gets back that that's
a whole different discussion the guys
that have done that I mean look at bonds
did it with people Clemens did it with
his trainer people have like sacrificed
other people's lives to keep a lie going
um and then you had uh I can't remember
the picture from Houston who left after
and said he was ashamed and you know he
told everybody it's exactly what was
happening and all the things well
Springer said the following he said I
feel horrible for our sport our game uh
you know our fans our city our
organization just fans in general
Springer said I regret everything yeah
and I go back to Sheila Joe Jackson who
people still say was not part of that
whole thing I don't think all the guys
were in it on it and clearly they
weren't that was the 1929 White Sox what
was that they threw the World Series and
he was never a part of the whole thing
apparently but man he very carefully hit
400 right it didn't matter apparently
yeah yeah but I don't think got the hits
when they didn't matter I don't know
what what the what's the death penalty
right taking the World Series away uh
suspending them from the postseason I
don't know you're talking about a
multi-billion dollar and you can't take
uh draft picks away you can't take yeah
you can and I think they did take two
picks from them in the draft or
something like that which is that's
correct they had draft picks and then
they uh gave up their General management
but think about it but think about what
are they doing what do they do in
college football though in college
football you can't go to uh you can't go
to a bowl you can win the championship
you can't no and but you can't do that
for a professional sports franchise why
because the first of all let's be very
clear about winning the World Series
it's a multi-billion dollar like spoon
when you think about the finances
involved it's incredible right how much
money they make somebody's got to go to
Disney right but you're not talking
about uh Alabama uh or Nebraska or
Oklahoma State where the school just
marches on baseball and the postseason
is everything to play for if you have no
fans would show up the next year you
would put the team in a position to
possibly go bankrupt unless the rest of
the league is going to support them
financially which they're not yeah so I
mean if you're really Limited in how far
you can go and I think that's part of
the reason why people push the sides did
you see you know again for me I
understand the position you're taking
with them when it comes down to how you
handled uh the Astros and how you handle
Trevor Bauer there's a lack of
consistency of what's getting punishment
so cheating is not punished but the way
I live my personal life is but isn't
that what we're dealing with in sport
and actually we're dealing with that in
every facet of life right now the
inconsistency with which we apply the
law my bedroom is officially your
business right right no I listen I no
it's not the government and ruling
forces don't belong in the church the
bedroom or the school
I this became this but this wasn't about
the bedroom this was about a man beating
a woman in that's what we were led to
believe that's what the media framed
this as right because it wasn't this was
about two adults having consensual sex
more than once
and all of the evidence I saw supported
Trevor's claims that nothing outside of
what she was expecting happened happened
and she's a be back customer you know
when when you go to a restaurant you
don't like the food you don't come back
she came back let's go back let's take
it to the extreme yeah you know
a man rapes a woman the woman doesn't
look the man back up for a second visit
we were being this was being positive as
as he abused this woman and and and
nothing of the story was the actual
story but the framework the media put
around this to me was criminal and it's
again I I will be stunned if he ever
puts a uniform on the big leagues again
Pat back to this cheating concept those
are kind of reminiscent of the
conversation we have with Andrew Tate
you remember what he said you familiar
with this guy Andrew told you it's kind
of everywhere these days
um and he talked about cheating at all
costs right we're talking about athletes
Competitive Edge how can you get a
competitive Advantage
um you know what you're willing to do to
cheat and he gave an example of if you
had uh a pickup basketball game you had
five people on one team five people
another team and no referees and said
all right the winner gets 10 grand how
much cheating do you think would happen
to win 10 grand for like pick a
basketball game right now extrapolate
that to politics to mult 10 billion
dollar Industries you don't think a
little bit of cheating is going to go on
we're talking about for money and power
of trillions right and that I mean
that's why we're seeing what we're
seeing and we're
we're being influenced the way we are
what is that right there so 2019 players
pull them out into 80 million dollars
the World Series Championship Nationals
uh received 29 million dollars of that
grand total while the American League
champion Astros received 19 million yep
the Nationals voted to award 61 full
shares which amounted to 300 and that's
82 000 that's just players pool that's
right that's one of the greatest people
coming in that's not people buying
tickets that's not yeah you could make
the greatest two-hour television show in
history if you could video the shares
meeting
so the shares meeting is basically where
you're only in the shares meeting if
you're on the roster the entire year and
basically you get in a room and you get
this you get to figure out who gets the
cut of the 29 million and how it gets
portioned out so for me it's all about
the clubhouse guys you've been in those
oh I've been in those meetings that's
per team per team so let's just say
there's there's I think the year we won
it was a couple hundred it was 350 Grand
or something like that and only the team
that wins the World Series got the
winning team the winning cheer was 350 a
player a person I'm sorry not a player
because for me it was a you include the
traveling secretary the trainers the
clubhouse guys the guys that are making
50 Grand a year get added oh this is
life-changing money for them this is
ever I mean and that is one of the but
you'll have players and I had players in
shares meetings making you know the
equivalent of 30 million dollars a year
now stand up and say I don't no we're
not giving that guy a share like wait
what
why the hell would you care because your
share is going to go from 350 to 346.
why would you care if we could give the
and again you're talking about
life-changing money what happens to the
Dynamics of how players view players the
whole player that's making all the money
makes a comment like that how do you
view it doesn't that hurt the locker
room it was always the and not always
the biggest
the wealthiest guys on the team would be
the ones bitching and moaning about the
little okay he's getting money it was
not always but it was those were the
guys that would stand up and go so weird
to me oh it was why is that what was
their mindset again human nature I
deserve because it's kind of like it's
because of me we're winning I should be
getting the most virus and it's so
awkward which is comfortable you're
saying that like the guy that carries
the bags that makes 40 50 Grand a year
when the team wins the World Series he's
eligible for a full share for 250 Grand
put anybody on the list you want how
many people are generally on the list uh
so it's again the only guys in the
meeting are the guys that were on the
roster the entire year so that's usually
between 15 and 20 guys because there's
usually no more than that you have guys
coming up and down so let's say let's
say 15. so then these employees right
you put in all the clubhouse guys which
might be between five and ten guys the
trainers the assistant trainers another
four or five guys the traveling
secretary and anybody awesome
and the coaches all get a full share
unless and so but again your talk
talking about and you think about those
Yankee teams that were winning year
after year after year those Clubhouse
guys were making bank and and
most of the teams I played on we were
always pretty good to those guys and
like you know I would tip my traveling
secretary 20 25 000 a year because he
was my wife away from home he took care
of all my travel and all my you know
when I was bitching at three in the
morning about something I bitched at him
so I made sure at the end of the year I
took care of those guys all it's been in
the clubhouse guys those guys they're
washing my underwear you know they're
doing the and and you know they are
always an incredibly like uh
very tight-knit part of the family that
would be the greatest book in history
Balfour by Jim Belton would be a comic
book if a clubhouse guy ever wrote a
book those guys know everything about
everybody what are Clubhouse guys
exactly these are they're doing laundry
they're carrying bags yeah
who handles all the equipment in the
locker room and all of the amenities in
the locker room the bathroom he's like
uh almost he's like uh you know the guy
that is in a bathroom in a fancy
restaurant or a fancy anything times 10
for 25 guys
25 spoiled millionaires he's got a group
of four to five guys who wash all your
clothes they'll run every errand a
player has go grab me this do this do
this and I you know so I would pick one
every year and I'd have one guy lean on
all year and I would tip him
excruciatingly large at the end of the
year because I knew I made his life hell
for five months but
they they if they're good at it those
guys on the road that's where the guys
make mice on the road you did typically
tip Clubhouse guys anywhere from 50 to
200 a day
and and I would pick a guy out in each
Clubhouse in each City that would be my
guy I need and I you know I wasn't a
high maintenance player by any stretch
but if I needed something I'd ask them
and then you those guys make can make
huge by the way I love this I love this
aspect of uh what happens the whole
everybody wins even the guys that are
going above and beyond they
participating the victory that's because
there's such a crucial part of it of
course right it's like Supply and
Logistics you know at the end of of a
campaign yeah the soldiers getting the
medals or the guys on the front lines
but the guys in Supply and Logistics
made life possible for everybody yeah
these are the same very much the same
way that makes sense that makes sense to
see that happen by the way Tom did you
know about this or no yeah and as a
matter of fact this is also an
opportunity where
um uh players that only do half a year
because remember it takes five years to
get a big contract and I'm going to be
on the 350 yeah 375 410 big gear oh I
can arbitrate right it all goes like
that and so it's changed now with the
with the minimum salary going through
the roof but yeah and and the new rules
that don't allow the teams to play games
with the 24-hour disabled list I'm not
about 350 000 shares at a time when
minimum salary was 40 50 Grand it's 1.8
million that's that's a big number
that's that's right right and just and
so actually that share goes that so if
you go to the postseason you get
postseason check yeah but I think the
point you were trying to make the reason
why you showed this is to say listen
they pay so much that's why the guys
cheat I don't think I don't think the
guys from the Astros were doing this
because they wanted a 350 000 auto check
yeah and I don't think the employees
were doing it because they wanted 350
000 check I think they just wanted they
knew a World Series means you know
you're going to get a bigger contract I
love the idea for a documentary of it
because there's also players that are in
there so let's say I'm a third year
player and I'm really good pitcher and
and I was eight and three but then I got
chip in my elbow and I was off the
roster for the second half of the year
I'm on the 40 Man IR effectively and
they can vote and they say you know what
that that Ellsworth guy first half of
the season eight and three he's
responsible
basically you vote in quarters quarter
half three quarters full for the most
part and so you know what you do is
you'd start out by eliminating the big
list you'd say anybody that was on the
roster that wasn't a full member gets at
least a quarter share and then you might
have three like in uh 04 jacobiel or an
07 Jacoby Ellsbury came up and played
like the last two months of the Season
which you know generally would be a
third of a share or a quarter of a share
but he was literally almost the MVP of
the postseason so he got a full share
and and for a guy that coming out of
college who votes that the people that
are in their vote for the players that
were on the roster are able to vote
those are the only people get the vote
who'll get to vote right nobody else is
in the room and how is the vote
structured what is it like Jordan okay
that's cool right that's cool but there
are some teams that will do like a
secret ballot so nobody finds the
noodles but we always made everyone I
was in it was like raise your hand I
like that yeah I like that because I
think there's a form of a pressure well
it's accountability yeah I never be
almost fist fights I I bet oh this is
very this is very uh
of course I mean this is life-changing
money it's not life-changing money for
the guy that's the Superstar so we were
just talking about how Manfred is
handling baseball and all this stuff if
there's one sport that hadn't gone woke
and it was like height in the corner
nobody but nobody was bothering it was
NHL and then we heard what happened this
week with the NHL yeah hey you guys are
not you know uh diverse enough and you
you saw this case here the NHL's first
internal demographic study found its
Workforce to be overwhelmingly white Kim
Davis NHL EVP of social impact uh uh
growth and legislative affairs has seen
the number is a first step towards
fixing a problem what are your thoughts
on this it's horseshit I mean it listen
this is why the country is where it is
when you're when your qualifications and
criteria to get a job are based on your
skin color and your religion you're not
picking the best people well look at the
vice president of the United States
there's not a bigger box of rocks in
existence than this woman and and she is
affirmative action live she's never done
anything that you would look at and say
well that merits her being someone in a
position of prominence and Power in this
country because she clearly understands
what's going on she doesn't have a grasp
of anything and and and when you have
I'll never forget this I don't know if
you if you ever saw this but when
Wikileaks came out and all of the all of
the emails from the Clinton campaign
were revealed and I I mean I I read
through tons of them and there was a
document and podesta was on it but it
was a document listing a bunch of
cabinet positions and sub-cabinet
positions and they had the position and
the candidates listed were uh what we
need we need a black or Latino we need a
homosexual in this one we need a uh an
Asian man in this position and none of
them had anything to do with
qualifications of the position and
you're starting to see that permeate in
the real world people are getting hired
and and promoted and are doing things
based on any anything but their job
qualifications and that's what I my
argument for as a conservative has
always been I don't care what color you
are I don't care who you sleep but then
I don't care you pray to are you a
law-abiding legal American citizen of
any color race who can achieve at the
job I need you to achieve to if you go
back and look at Trump's four years and
you look at the fact that the Liberals
would like to tell you look he hired and
fired so many people well I I think a
lot of them having known Mr Trump
president Trump since 2006 he's a
pragmatist he's a problem solver right
and I think what he thought was a lot of
people in the private sector their
success was going to translate into
government and it didn't so when they
they came in and he saw that they
weren't doing the job he said okay
you're fired and he moved some and
everybody else saw that as instability
and and unstable and I saw that as I
need to find the right person for the
job man woman doesn't matter
and then you have other administrations
who hire and never fire anybody and that
tells me that we're living their
mistakes because not everybody's right
for the job meaning it was like a favor
when they hired someone I owed you a
favor I hired you where Trump didn't
have a favor you helped get me elected I
promise you a position on the board
patient yeah here it is doesn't mean
you're the best person for the job but
go ahead I mean Pete budigen
really that's your guy hey that guy
fixed potholes right Indiana I mean
seriously you look at some of these
people and the challenges it's gotten so
ridiculous that we joke about it now did
you hear about the buildback better uh
the money that uh uh you know won the
most Biden calls it won the most
incredible
um you know what do you want to call it
uh infrastructure bills
it is incredible they just spend the
first it is they just spend the first
one they thought but it is they just
spend the first 20 million you know what
it is did you did you see this thing the
the first 20 million that was spent to
uh uh the sidewalks of this city and
they went and interviewed this people in
the city they said you know you're
getting the first 20 million what are we
doing with that 20 million we're gonna
heat your sidewalks so the ice can melt
the citizens that city is like what are
you talking about I get the wrong place
to spend the 20 million dollars on well
they're trying to block out the sun now
too have you seen that yeah they have
plans they're they're trying to actually
block it out you know Sports on the
field is the ultimate meritocracy the
fans don't care
um back in 2004 Calgary Flames uh made
it to the finals and uh lost to Tampa
and that's when the entire NHL kind of
flipped out because the retirement
community had a Stanley Cup yeah and um
your own again love us on that team and
he was beloved you know you would see up
in Calgary it was up there he was
absolutely beloved he was an
African-American on the ice it was can
you skate can you shoot are you valuable
to the team and I think when you look at
the NHL Gary is the worst commissioner
in professional sports which is really
hard to do because there's a lot of
competition to be the worst commissioner
okay the and you you sit back and say is
it a good thing to raise awareness so
that we make sure that everyone has an
opportunity for front office jobs and
everything yes it is but to the fans the
fans it's a meritocracy on the on the
court it's America accuracy on the ice
talking about uh the government spending
thing one of the things that that and I
get I don't want to say physically ill
but it's it's borderline I'll get acid
reflux at the at the discussion there's
32 000 homeless veterans in this country
every single night there should not be a
dollar of our government's money exiting
the borders of this country are being
spent for anything until they have a
roof over their heads and that just that
that I and I say that because you were
you were mentioning that that 20 million
I just saw something we're sending
something like uh 22 200 million 20
million to South America to uh help uh
transgender activities in the community
of South America
Tran like like uh dancers and I mean the
stuff that we're seeing in the United
States with these kids being put in
front of transgender these these the the
the the the the cross-dressing dancers
and all the things that are going and
it's like
it doesn't seem real to me we're arguing
about things that to me are
they're not they're not there's no logic
to the argument but the left is winning
because we're having the argument to
begin with why are we arguing about who
can vote in our election how is that an
argument can I go to Germany and vote in
their election or Mexico no why are
people allowed to come here and vote
if they don't if they're not citizens
why is and then secondly why are we even
arguing it but that's the win right
we're discussing something we shouldn't
even be discussing
that's like me coming in your house and
telling you how you should paint the
wall in your living room it's and I
don't even live in here
but again why are we arguing things that
aren't just they're not even logical
yeah why are we arguing about what
bathroom a man or a woman should be able
to use how is that a logical argument I
agree with you that can I make just one
point just that kind of a just to throw
my you know Counterpoint uh 100 with you
on the like the woke stuff it's a it's
it's obviously getting very annoying you
know I think Democrats are going to pay
the price in the midterms we're about to
see in less than a month three weeks
um but
you use Kamala as an example okay so
what part of it is Optics marketing
meaning she wasn't they didn't they
didn't I mean in all fairness curve they
didn't pick her up on the side of a
highway she was a Senator she was
re-elected the senator called the
California segregation correct right but
some of it is Optics meaning he's all
Optics correct so hear me out you know
he said I want a a black female to be my
VP it could have been her it could have
been Stacey Abrams could have been
Condoleezza Rice it could have been
Susan Rice who arguably would have been
better candidates but at the same time I
mean Trump did something similar now
here we go he said all right who's gonna
be my VP well I'm going for Optics here
who's going to help me get votes it
could have been Chris Christie not two
New Jersey guy New York a little much
all right I kind of want to get the
Christian Evangelical vote hmm who
represents that well you got this person
got this person this guy Mike Pence
could be something so
and I think Mike Pence was very
deservative of the job but ultimately my
point is he was solving for something
right he was solving solving for Optics
agenda but I don't look at those as
similarly aligned interests in the sense
that I'm looking to hire a black woman
or I'm looking to hire somebody that
will bring me a voting block that black
woman didn't necessarily bring you a
bloating a voting block they would say
that she did well but if she got women
to vote but see that's the bigotry of
low expectations of the left the left
believe that black people are too stupid
to get their own ID to get their own
driver's license they're too stupid to
get on the internet so if they're too
stupid to anything they'll vote for us
just because we put a black woman in
office and the black people I know
they're not that stupid at all not even
close in fact they get offended when you
ask them questions like that but the
bigotry of of low expectations from the
left drives a lot of their decision
making and saying well listen if we put
a Jewish guy here then we'll get the
Jewish vote and if we put a black woman
here we'll get the black boat someone
just say that's just playing politics so
I mean what the Pence as an example
we're going to get the Christian vote
which is a Chris Christie the debate for
me is it now is is people talk and you
know every second I don't get a blocked
number that I that gets through I get a
help us raise money for this campaign
we're all getting that by the way it's
election season I'm getting that left
and right I continually think to myself
I don't know in my lifetime and I don't
know anybody that does I've never seen a
commercial that's made me vote for
somebody
I've never seen a commercial and said
you know what I'm gonna go vote for that
person but they would have you us
believe that whatever side raises the
most money is going to win the election
which basically is them saying you're
too stupid to think for yourself so
we're going to buy your vote with this
well most people already before they
walk into the voting booth know what
they're voting for do you know anybody
in the last 20 years that's walked into
a voting booth unsure
do you I'm there right now but I don't
know where I'm going these days no
that's not true I swear
you know who you'll never vote for no I
just I know no no the listen I think all
three of you know who you're walking
into the second you walk into a voting
room I'm very convinced of that I was
also that person these days I'm very
unsure
but I think yes multiple times like you
know who you're not voting wow I'm not a
trump fan yeah I'm not going to reverse
course all of us but what I'm saying to
you is that is a position though you
know who you are not voting vote for
Trump he would not I'm not a trump fan
wow that's that what would it take for
you to vote for Biden what would it take
how about this listen how about this
hear me out where to place when's the
last time you voted for a Democrat
Clinton okay so it's been 30 years now
and I saw this the other day and it's I
think it's absolutely essential to to
where we are and I think it's going
forward we're at a point of no return
and I say that because you when I was
growing up and I was not very political
when I was growing up but you had people
left to center right of Center and then
you had Center and all the things the
Democrats Republicans of our childhood
are gone
but we're at a point in time where
there's no going back and there is no
peace because both sides
see each other as inherently evil right
and I tend to believe as a patriotic
flag waving American uh and all the and
again I've known president Trump since
2006. all the things you can say about
him you can say about them but the fact
of the matter this country in every
metric possible was better under his
presidency except for the fact that the
left was angry bitter and hateful
the economy minority employment uh
female employment the stock every by
every measurable metric that we measure
that we have in the past measured
Presidents by we were better
and by every those same metrics in the
last two were far far worse and and the
fact that we're having a conversation
around who you would vote for that blows
me away that blows me away to think that
an educated person would ever consider
allowing Democrats to be in power again
for the rest of our lives as long as
people live
I've watched I mean we've all watched it
for two years
that this the destruction there that
they've wrought on the foundational
principles of this country and listen
you can say oh you want this Foundry
this country was found on Judo Christian
principles it just was you don't have to
agree with it you can you can want it to
go in a different way but that's the way
it is
and the fact that we're having these
discussions now about
who who I've been alive for two I
watched it for two years I've seen it
happen for two years I've seen the moral
Decay listen I grew up at my dinner
table right when I did something wrong
I'd slap on the back of that I grew up
at a dinner table and and the but the
farther from the dinner table in the
Bible this country's gotten the farther
down the toilet it's gotten and it's
just been sad to watch how do we get
here in your opinion how do we get here
apathy
for gosh 30 or 40 years we had 40 50
voter turnout
we we let them get where they are and I
think there's a certain level of
corruption in the process that has
gotten people in to office because you
can't convince me that a majority of
people in Maxine Waters District or
aoc's District or Nancy Vote or Eric
Schiff these people are are the dumbest
of the dumb there's there's just
there I mean listen we we know that
there is a massive amount of election
fraud in the last election how much I
don't know that we'll ever find out but
we know because we've seen the evidence
and and you know I was up at three in
the morning when the vote total for
Biden Changed by 2 million and trumps
didn't move an inch and I was like wait
a minute what just happened
but you know you say something like that
now
and you're you're a conspiracy theorist
I God my God I don't know how many years
ago I mentioned something I I didn't
know what Q was
and I somehow somebody sent me a Twitter
link or something and I and I wrote down
you know this is actually kind of
interesting I want to follow this and
find out what it is why I became a q
disciple from that point on doesn't
matter what I've ever said or what I
actually said but what do you mean you
you someone labeled you I've been I've
been a q Anon person since then and my I
like everything else from my mom taught
me how to speed read when I was young I
I have 15 or 20 books sitting by my bets
I read everything about everything that
I can find out yeah and I like to find
out about stuff and so I was curious
about it
and they come to find out that
everything they've ever said was going
to happen never happened and and it's
it's pretty much a group of people that
are all bought in on on conspiracy stuff
that isn't happening and hasn't happened
and none of it's ever come to fruition
so you're calling out Q right now but
but no but my point is those those
niches exist everywhere in every sort of
conspiracy theory and and but but here's
the thing they're not all conspiracies
the key the trouble is finding out
figure out which ones are right are real
and are not and and you know it's I
think in a lot of ways if you the
internet
proven to be incredibly valuable and
unbelievably dangerous at the same time
because of
you know the I don't know what to say
power but you know being able to find
out and look and research and understand
the world going on around you in a much
larger way now than we ever could
um that's where I get back to how could
anybody
if Trump runs against whoever next
election how can anybody not vote for
him any logical adult rational educated
person not
not a good public speaker not a funny
guy by any Street nothing worse than a
funny someone who's not funny that
thinks they are
but he delivered on literally every
campaign promise he made
and you you cannot like him he's easy
not to like I like him I've again I've
known him for for a while and and I know
the personal side I know the guy's got a
heart
an enormous heart and that's my phone
again sorry about that but the fact of
the matter is you know where we're at
now after two years of this but I think
there's such a yearning in this country
for something new something fresh we've
seen the trumpets we've seen the Trump
show but hold on a second we've also
seen the Bible show neither of them are
what the country wants well but again
from a Max Capacity but we asked for it
remember what the big cry was during the
Trump run up to the election we want
someone who isn't the establishment we
want someone who isn't a politician
that's what it looks like an outsider to
drain the swamp that's what it looks
like it's again
no everybody the left wanted it
you're right yes
this is what it looks like when a guy
who isn't bought by anybody isn't owned
by anybody and is a business Problem
Solver oh does he have you know I love
the people call him you know he's filed
for bankruptcy guys had over 500
business transactions he's filed for
bankruptcy 12 times I'll take that
batting average
I mean it but the hatred is so deep and
so deranged that it makes people I think
do illogical things do you think that
that hatred
obviously coming from the left and a lot
of it's some from the traditional Rhino
Republicans as well yeah right I mean
that that exists right do you think
that's going anywhere anytime soon no oh
God no all right no it's just growing
right no it it yeah so so am I so my
question is are you ready to double down
on that knowing or is it time to maybe
anoint a new candidate there was like a
scientist there would be nobody to be
anointed because the game is foment the
anger against the opponent right so it
doesn't matter whether it's Trump or
this person or Biden or this person
you're going to see this massive game
unfold to foment as much controversy and
anger in the other side that is the
reality of our elections by the way Tom
you're not wrong you're absolutely right
but amplify that times 10 when Trump's
name is
maybe in one neighborhood but in the
other neighborhood amplify it times 10
when Biden's name is that's my point but
but nobody's got one-sided nobody gets
more hate than Trump nobody nothing
close no not even close nope Obama
we are at a point where both sides see
the other side as inherently evil and
there's no middle ground anymore and
that's dangerous because there's nobody
out there that's looking to put that
bridge over troubled water and do you
think Trump's gonna be that guy no no so
the country will be again it'll go in my
opinion the Trump the the things that
people Matt that matter like your income
the price of gas your 401k all the
things that matter to Everyday Americans
gets better
otherwise it doesn't to most people
today that are alive today right this is
pure history this is like ancient
history but there was a time
when President Reagan once a week had
lunch at the White House with Tip
O'Neill yeah and we had us we had to
take care of the house for those that
don't correct and we had a degree of
Civility between the two sides even
though tip was very much about welfare
very much actually he was more about
social security Medicare and increasing
benefits to make it a permanent
retirement Reagan was like I think you
have to moderate that and there were
things that they disagreed but they were
both civilly at the table and we've lost
that no well that's never coming back
but that didn't start with Trump this
divisiveness no no you might argue with
that no you may argue the country
no come on hold on here
it was more racially divided during
President Obama's presence yeah but it
started before Obama occur it's always
been that where did it really start a
lot of people will say that it happened
during Clinton and Newt Gingrich okay
where he went when he went no yeah
during the whole the whole impeachment
over a freaking [ __ ] nurt went Newt
went full nuclear on this guy I do find
it funny that the people that were
stalking and laughing and getting all
perturbed about the fact we were upset
over Clinton getting a blow job in the
White House are the ones that want the
moral compass with Trump I think that is
funny but the fact of the matter is pres
in my mind the biggest opportunity this
country lost was when we elected a black
president and instead of being the guy
who bridged the Gap he widened the Gap
in ways that I never ever expected his
hatred or his outward disdain for law
enforcement was was very open and very
public using statistics that were
absolutely not true his stuff about the
climate change and the 97 which is still
it was one of the biggest fallacies ever
all of those things he perpetuated and
he could have just said you know what
this is a time to heal but I I agree
with you to a certain extent but like
I'm not a big Obama guy the last
Democrat that I truly truly truly loved
I was a Clinton guy I grew up like my
dad was a big Clinton guy but some of
the divisiveness wasn't his fault there
was people that genuinely hated the fact
yeah that there was a black Democrat in
office it's never the president's fault
the president has the chance to amplify
someone else's message and unless he's
openly saying race war which was never
the case right I mean these
it's it's it but President Obama had
opportunities multiple opportunities I
think I think every president has
multiple opportunities but I think he
went so far to the one side that we've
never seen before anti-police I mean he
was very anti-police which that's your
president like you know if you want to
say that Trump's steering the nation in
their opinion on certain things you
can't deny the fact that Obama did that
very thing in ways that were
self-destructive
yeah it's interesting because Obama
seems like a very rational logical actor
but especially when like the Trayvon
Martin things happens and he used things
used words like that could have been my
son that could have been me obviously he
was acting emotionally in those
instances right
and even what was the situation in
Dallas where police officers were shot
five police officers murdered right and
then at the funeral he stood there and
talked about the inherent racism within
the police department yeah right like an
emotional actor that's not your job as a
president United States is the exact
opposite of those things so then the
question becomes a follow-on though by
the way Kurt moving forward we we don't
like election deniers on the podcast
please don't do that specifically this
is if you can please show this a tweet
if we can go to this I don't like this
kind of stuff being said on the podcast
Nancy Pelosi tweeted this back in May
2016 2017 and it's still on there just
so if folks want to find it our election
was hijacked there's no question
Congress has a duty to protect our
democracy and follow the fact so let's
please not do that again Kurt please
follow those questions the other people
that makes me the hypocrisy is just yeah
mind-boggling but you know you know what
I was going to ask here's what I was
going to ask okay so what's the solution
what's the solution so is the solution
letting bad ideas go so far out that it
gets so exposed that finally you know
JFK Democrats and Republicans
conservatives say listen man dude I got
a lot more common with you than I do
with these other I don't know what the
hell is going on over here do we let it
to get that bad is that what we have no
other choice to is the other option
which you got Adam kinzinger you know uh
uh comes out a couple days ago says
Misty eyed Adam kinzinger says
conservatives will be the first to die
in a civil war so is the second option
you know we go through some like this
where in a response to a comment about
Republican on Twitter Adam kins are
going to openly fantasize about a
country being driven towards Civil War
and suggested that anti-war
conservatives will be the first to die
Kensington made the comments in response
to a user who went on a mile rant about
Republicans not supporting the war
effort in Ukraine referring to them as
fascists and labeling them as their gqp
party True Rewards have never been
spoken kinzinger replied spoiled people
who have never seen War like to play
dress up if there is a civil war they
will be the first to pass away because
Walgreens will run out of heart medicine
right so he makes comments like this so
option number one let bad ideas uh play
out and everyone's going to unite number
two Civil War number three you know uh
unify bring everybody to get on one side
you know together to sit down and talk
number four do what musk and some others
are talking about hey just vote
Republican what is the solution number
three bringing everybody together that's
I think we're way past the option I
don't think that's gonna happen I don't
think there's anybody out there that
that can happen I I don't I I think
we're living number one letting these
ideas get so rotten that the bill Mars
or the world go wait a minute I'm not on
the left anymore because that's idiocy
um and Joe Rogan who is who is very far
left and and his understanding that the
right actually isn't what the left would
have you believe it is
um
the Civil War thing for me is and one
thing I've learned uh growing up as a
military brat and being around the
military is the last people in the world
who want conflict are the ones who have
seen it
they understand the price and and you
know having been in and seen an active
war zone and and seeing what it looks
like and what it does you know I would
certainly never want to but I'm also on
not even remotely uncomfortable at the
thought of standing up to defend and
fight for my country physically if
that's what it meant
um
I don't again I said I think both sides
are so far apart and see each other as
such bad people that there is no
Bridging the Gap my question has been
for 10 years
um
former military and Military and law
enforcement I and I you know having kind
of spread myself into those circles and
and tried to have those people as much
as I can in my life I asked the same
question
Mike I'm gonna look to you
if the rubber meets the road if I'm
starting to see videos of ATF agents and
FBI agents knocking on the doors of
law-abiding Americans asking them if
they're they possess a certain item that
they bought legally and if they did so
would they turn it over I never thought
that was even remotely something that
would ever happen
and my question is to law enforcement
what are you going to do are you going
to enforce the law you know to be or or
an order that you know to be
unconstitutional because the oath you
took was foreign and domestic right
enemies foreign and domestic
what does a domestic enemy look like
because my argument is it looks sort of
like what we're seeing it looks sort of
like people who are
locking the country down for two years
over what we now know was enormous power
play and was a bunch of [ __ ] and we
were being lied to about the vaccine and
all the other things around that and
we're finding out that all the the
quote-unquote deaths were those with
comorbidities and 90 of these people
were elderly and overweight and had all
the things that people die from the flu
from
all of the like that's the thing is I
get the feeling that the Liberals that I
see and the Democrats that I see truly
hate well I mean the president came out
and talked about
fighting
Mega Americans right if you're going to
fight the government we have nuclear
weapons and f-16s I mean open I've never
heard
to think that a president would even
utter that much less say at a press
conference is mind-boggling to me I I
think there's a combination of all of
those things that like I said I think
we're living number one I think we're
letting
bad ideas play out yeah and I think we
feel like we have to I don't I think we
feel like we're powerful and I'll say
this Jim Jordan
I'm so I'm a fan I'm so tired of seeing
him complain on Twitter
and I've I've written to him a couple
times saying just shut up you got
elected to fix it stop complaining on
Twitter and do something about it
because you sound like a voter you sound
like me I'm complaining to you
and you're who are you I you if you
can't do anything then resign and put
somebody in the office that has the guts
to do something because I'm tired of
hearing them Rand Paul and all of them
again same thing committee after
committee after committee no one ever
actually does anything what can they do
I I don't know
but I know I'm powerless unless I take
up arms against and then a sitting
government which I'm not going to do
yeah what I can't do anything I have
don't we elect these people to steer the
country and by steer I mean hold on to
the wheel and move us in a Direction
what if if we know people are breaking
the law which we know we know the the
the last Democratic party in the last
Administration that was Democrat
weaponized the doj
I mean that much we know Comey and all
the things that went with that I mean we
watched Comey James Comey stand up in
front of the mic and talk about
Clinton's crimes and say a bad word not
enough to prosecute
and now we we I mean I follow along some
of the Giuliani stuff the stuff that's
been done to him since
Trump has been in my in May facets that
I've read unconstitutional and against
the law
again law enforcement agents knocking on
Americans doors asking
to have items that were legally
purchased to turn that in and then being
told and the person saying do you have a
warrant no I don't have a warrant but
you don't need to be a jerk about it you
know you can just give me the item and
we'll go away and he's like no I'm not
doing that and he's like we'll probably
see you again down the road like they're
threatening us
that's the gov that's that's Russia
that's Eastern Europe that's fascism at
its core and it's happening live and and
the the internet's allowing us to see it
that's the even worse part and we're
still doing nothing about it
Tom how do you process it what do you
think is going to happen with this is it
playing it out is it playing it out is
it let it play out is it number two you
know uh uh a civil war is going to
happen a republican is going to get
elected is it what do you think is going
to happen unifying forces in the history
of America have always been very violent
um and it's very sad 911 was a unifying
force a tremendous unifying force we
didn't care what color you were
we didn't care anything about it we were
just tall
we were hurting we were pro-us we were
pro-us and we saw us getting together
those uh was it nine days later and the
NFL was this healing moment on Sunday
and we talked about praying together we
talked about unifying we talked about
helping we talk about reaching out
unifying forces are usually very very
violent and the the problem with the
political structure is it's it's a power
and economic structure it's not just a
power structure and the the where words
have to be weaponized you have to create
such hatred to move these voting blogs
at least that's what they think and you
take billions and billions of dollars
from people that want hundreds and
hundreds of favors later
um that's the way this works
um
and I I I think you need to get there's
got to be a unifying force and I don't
wish it on this country I don't wish it
on any person but there's got to be a
unifying force that comes together of it
and it's usually it's usually when
people realize we don't have it so bad
and something really horrible has just
gone down and my goodness we do have it
better than we thought we did you guys
are at the tip of the spear in a sense
uh in this ideological war you talk you
your job in a sense one of the most
important jobs is to bring
people from both sides
to the public and and and and expose
them in good and bad for what they are
and what they believe and what and when
you look at the fact that our government
is trying to
enforce
its mandate on our speech
that should be I mean free every book in
the world
in America is legal to read everything
you can say in the world other than
causing harm to another human being is
legal to say in this country it has to
be under the First Amendment you cannot
like it you can be offended by it but
those two things have to be true those
are no longer true here
I just saw something this morning I was
reading them and this blew me away
apparently Amazon uh the largest seller
of books in the world
has banned an enormous staple of books
based on uh order from the Department of
Justice
that should scare the [ __ ] out of people
and you know all the things happening to
these people in in uh at the FBI showing
up or investigating uh someone from the
news media that is writing a story about
Biden and all the things
there's it's so distant from people that
are reading it they can't translate or
or come to the conclusion what if that's
me
yeah and and it started out because
apparently there was an author in Russia
who is one of the one of the Alexander
Dugan yes the philosophy yes yeah and
and his books are prominent to in every
educated person's bookshelf because like
apparently he's written I've never read
anything he's written but this gentleman
went to look for them and Tucker Carlson
had mentioned that he went to look for
them and they're there's not one on the
site none of them on the site so then
what the left does is well it's a you
know when they when they have this I
love this argument oh it's a private
company they don't have well it yeah
there's no First Amendment issues until
the government is involved in the
decision-making process which is we need
you to ban these books we want you to
ban these books well again
a book can't offend you unless you read
it
so you know and then the the the the the
throwback is well the the conservatives
in the South are trying to ban books
well it's my understanding that the
books they're trying to not ban but
remove from elementary schools are
basically adult
pornography or whatever that might be
and I could be wrong but
this is the I mean we're have again
but we're having discussions that five
years ago we would have just said no
that'll never happen
and not now we're living it yeah my name
is scary part my thing is you know in in
how many times is it like a kid is grow
grows up in a Family household that
parents get a divorce
one side of the family tells you stories
about the other side of the parent well
yeah let me tell you who your mom was
let me tell you your dad was and the kid
could believe it for five years
sometimes ten years sometimes 20 years
and then 20 years later like why'd you
say that about Mom why'd you say that
about that that wasn't true you made me
not like Dad for four years right
because that's what's happening and the
kid is in the middle experience mom and
dad getting a divorce and the kid is the
one that loses 10 20 years of his life
right so to me I think America is my
opinion I have four kids that's where my
opinion let me tell you I feel that pain
I mean I'm I I was willing to put and
still willing to put five billion
dollars on the line if Trump and Obama
are willing to do a three-hour podcast
together to figure out a way to get
people to come together and talk on what
they actually agree on because one is
the voice for Mega the other one is the
voice for the the left what can we do to
bring them together right because more
people are going to sit there and say
this kind of does make sense America's
especially before systemic racism yeah
right President Obama believes inherent
systemic racism in this country which we
know there's racism in this country
there's always going to be racism in
this country because we're a free
country and you're allowed to be racist
we've marginalized those people the clan
no longer has a voice at any table that
matters to anyone they still exist but
if you had left had their way they would
Define hate and they would get be able
to jail people that they deemed were
hate speech that's a perfect example is
that that gets back to Maga is seen as
this Ultra racist movement and President
Obama believes this country is
systemically racist
those two things don't have a meat in
the middle
right I mean we can listen I am as
conservative Finance fiscally
conservative as anybody on the planet
like socially I don't care I don't care
my middle son started the lgbtq club in
high school I had kids that were
transitioning coming in and out of my
house my whole my son's eyes really
never ever mattered to me I didn't care
we opened our home to everybody I don't
care about stuff like that has nothing
to do with what kind of person you are
how you treat me or how I treat you
but if you listen to but if you're going
if you Google me I'm a I'm an
islamophobe I'm a homophobe I'm a trans
all the things that's that's an
intentional people intentionally are out
there ruining other people
and again just the Justice cabinet
hearing was was it was an insight into
who we are as a nation right now and in
many ways and that was embarrassing and
uncomfortable as anything I've ever seen
well Kurt you know you're talking about
the system and and I'm with you the
system on both sides is screwed up but
also you know we're in we're in election
season candidates matter like you
brought up Jim Jefferies right exactly
you said Jim Jordan yeah yeah
um you know for your
um
advocating Bush right so but the
candidates matter like if you look on
the right you've got situations like Oz
or Herschel Walker or some of the clowns
that Borat you know interviewed whatever
that whole thing is who is America and
then you have if you go deeper down that
rabbit hole in Alabama they were putting
up a guy Roy Moore who you talk about
what some of these sexual allegations
what he was doing was freaking
ridiculous but then on the left you've
got the Maxine Waters of the world or
um the problem is you just said the word
allegations right and listen I'm not
defending World more but the point is
you don't have to do anything anymore
you just have to be alleged to if you're
alleged to you're guilty so so Jim
Jordan molested wrestlers at college or
allegedly but if you look at anybody on
the right they'll tell you he is and and
that's where so anybody that that and
that was one of the reasons why I
decided not to run for office when I
realized that families were now on the
table the media can do and say whatever
they want about your family if they if
you're especially if you're conservative
and it just seemed like it's not worth
the price no one nothing's worth the
price and and and that's we're at that
extreme where where
I mean God there's so many examples it
is honestly hard to think of just one
but in the last five or six years think
of the people that have been canceled
and we find out later the canceling act
never actually happened a tweet that
they did in high school or some stuff
like that yeah what comes to mind is
freaking Al Franken yeah right like this
I I mean I liked them on SNL he was a
senator from Minnesota he freaking
stepped down because he like gave a lady
a hug and went to give her a kiss and
whatever that [ __ ] situation was it's
a it's a nothing Burger but he gets so
caught up in that that cancel culture
has canceled some people that started
the culture itself I mean which is
poetic justice but nobody can survive
that system nobody you know if you go
back and find every tweet ever or every
social media experience or you talk to
somebody who went to high school with
you I'm sure you said something in high
school that was probably this is why
you shouldn't apologize unless you truly
truly truly truly did something wrong
you should hey man that's my opinion I'm
sticking to it and the I think that's
why I sleep good at night because I I've
made mistakes but I know who I am I know
I'm I'm never been malicious the only
people I can't stand are bullies and and
I I know I've never tried to hurt people
so I'm okay with him did you say that
you didn't want to be going to the Hall
of Fame I am like you made it no I said
at this point I didn't want to remove me
I want it off the ballot yeah you said
that yeah and what was your rationale
for that I didn't want to go through the
process anymore every year it came up my
family was subjected my kids especially
to social interactions that they didn't
want didn't Merit didn't deserve you
know your dad's a racist well what did
he actually by the way you defended your
daughter was epic I mean that's when
everybody had to come to your side and
you know give you pay your respect on
the way you backed her up because you
were celebrating uh and then Reggie
Jackson said what Reggie Jackson said
hey you know the only reason you're not
in Hall of Fame is because you feel
freedom of speech [ __ ] you know
whatever something like that he said I'm
okay with that because I've never met
anybody that didn't say Reggie Jackson
was an [ __ ] so I you know care about
Reggie Jackson Mr October is an [ __ ]
we're in the middle of October right now
yeah he's but but again I you know
people that have I've never you know I
played 22 years in baseball never had a
teammate fan Clubhouse guy trainer
anybody I've ever been interacted with
in my lifetime has ever said I did
anything or said anything racist but I'm
racist he says quote unquote freedom of
speech you got your ass out of
Cooperstown bro yeah whatever and again
he's an [ __ ] so I don't care I mean I
my dad told me early in life don't ever
live your life for the opinions of
people you don't know
and it made doing what I did a lot
easier in that sense in the sense that
like again I'm true to myself I'm sure
I've said things that are I know I've
said things that I shouldn't have said
I've noticed the things I don't want to
say or should have done but it's never
been about I've never done anything to
to willfully or harm somebody or hurt
somebody could what do you do nowadays
uh well set I have a uh I live in
Tennessee about 30 minutes south of
Nashville I have an animal rescue Farm
uh and uh actually my my last llama
passed away last night Rosie my llama
passed away last night so it was kind of
a tough morning sorry to hear but no but
and it's I I love animal I grew up in
Alaska so when you grow up in Alaska you
learned to shoot a rifle because getting
eaten by a bear on the way to school is
like a real thing right so you learn
firearm discipline but I also learned an
insane affinity for wildlife and nature
and my dad was a big hunter I've never
been a hunter but I understand that
whole thing but I grew up with a love of
animals and and I've always had one so
uh it was just natural for me to to
gravitate that way and I have a I have a
huge animal well not huge but I have a
rescue llamas goats pigs all of it and
that's where I find peace and comfort a
lot and that's what you do full-time
right now I I don't so like I said my
Monday and Saturday the exact same day
except that Sunday's football you know I
I I'm retired uh are you all sports are
you
hockey my two my oldest son and my
youngest son were both goalies playing
hockey my youngest son played Juniors my
youngest son is contemplating
a military life
um but uh I I don't I I don't watch any
baseball you don't follow baseball I
can't it's hard to watch I can't it's so
hard to watch now
um it's uncomfortable to watch like why
well because I was raised at a point in
time and I know this is gonna sound like
the you know the old man yelling at the
leaf on his lawn but I was raised
that as a starting pitcher those nine
innings were yours I was raised you know
it my goal wasn't wins it was 245
Innings a year because that meant I went
seven Innings every night for 35 nights
but and I was raised by Johnny Padres as
a pitching coach who was one of the
greats and and I watched these guys
coming out of the game after the fifth
inning and they're tipping their hat and
I'm thinking to myself you should be
ashamed of yourself I mean there's still
four Innings of this and it's not really
the player's fault because it's the way
the business has gone they've really
they got middle relief yeah there's so
much money in these arms that these kids
have to get to the big leagues of their
investment the team's investment screwed
so these kids are I came to the big
leagues I had six or seven hundred
innings in the minor leagues I had a
couple 200 inning seasons in the minor
leagues these kids are throwing 180
Innings a year and making 40 million
dollars a year and it's hard to watch
and the so the ace has gone away and if
you think about it when I but not when I
was coming up but probably right before
this last generation the starting
pitchers always provided you the the the
hero and the villain right Maddox
against Clemens
that was that it's backstory to a game
that no longer happens you don't only
have four or five guys the suresers or
the kershaws who oh my God this guy's
pitching I'll buy a ticket those guys
don't exist anymore because you know
Jacob degrom's gonna go six innings and
that that's just a different game and
and
this this influx of sabermetrics which I
again I buy into saber metrics I bought
into them in 1995. I was the I was way
ahead of that curve in the sense that I
didn't care about home runs and RBIs and
those [ __ ] stats I wanted to know
swing percentages when is The Hitter
going to swing because Greg Maddox said
the key to pitching is the percentages
well the key the key to pitching is to
throw a strike when the hitter is taking
in a ball when he's swinging
you just have to know when those times
are very simple idea like everything
else though with the complex formula and
so I studied and and the the the
preeminent moment in my career was I
watched Tony Gwyn go five for five I was
pitching a Sunday game and Saturday
night 20 going went five for five and he
was on the news afterwards and he said
yeah I kind of knew everything was
coming I was in counts I got comfortable
I knew what he was going to throw in
those counts and I'm thinking holy [ __ ]
I have no chance of getting this guy out
tomorrow none he knows everything I'm
gonna do and I thought
now wait a minute hitters are kind of
creatures that happen so I started
studying and and realized I could break
the strikes down down into you know 15
quadrants nine in the strike zone three
on the corners and hitters would swing
at different had different swing pads
yeah in those count in those categories
so in my mind because I couldn't
understand I watched Greg Maddox
throwing 88 for the 1.62 era I'm
throwing 95 and I'm getting my ass
handed to me and I'm like this doesn't
make any sense and it was all about
basketball command so I said listen I'm
gonna find the blue areas which are the
cold areas for I'm gonna find the blur
areas on every hitter and I can throw my
fastball there so the the my what I did
was I developed fastball command so I
could manipulate the ball three four
five inches at the time around the
strike zone and I knew where you
couldn't hit the ball so if you had a
really big blue spot it's one Aaron
judge you can't strike out 175 times a
year and not have holes
it's why in the postseason those guys
generally don't translate you strike out
175 times you're not going to hit well
in the postseason because the guy you're
not going to see the number four and
five starters you're not going to see
the middle of a bullpen you're going to
see the top three guys and the back
three guys and that's it
let me tell you I can I can sit here
listen to you for for hours I truly
enjoyed listening to you I've been very
quiet on this podcast just to listen to
because the stories whether it's
baseball whether it's your thoughts your
life experiences it's fascinating and I
look forward to the next one we do here
one funny story sure please all right
Joe West is an Umpire in the big leagues
he just retired he don't part more games
than anybody I am at a banquet in
Philadelphia sitting next to their adult
and Joe West and it's in Philadelphia
Philadelphia hated Joe West they sold
dart boards with his face as the
bullseye and I I didn't know Joe but I
knew him as an Umpire right Cowboy Joe
West and he is uh he's a country singer
in the offseason
yeah but he was he was a prick on the
field like a real he was a jerk tough
guy
so I'm sitting next to him and he starts
talking to me and I'm talking he's funny
like he's genuinely funny he gets up
after Darren and he says he he tells
this joke he said you know I just
realized that the reason Darren Dalton
is this guy is because Darren Dalton
thinks this is eight inches
about Fourth of July of that year I'm
pitching in Florida now the thing one
thing I've known about my career is I
didn't walk hitters right
um and so it's the sixth inning we're
playing the Marlins in 97 see the
Marlins won the World Series that's
right I was there Gary Sheffield seventh
inning sixth inning or seventh inning I
throw strike nine he walks Joe calls it
a ball I've walked down my fifth or
sixth hitter I don't walk six hitters a
month and I was on I had my stuff and
Joe calls it a ball
and uh it goes back to after Joe told
that story I got up and told a story I
said you know I just figured something
out I saw Joe Weston in Montreal this
winter this summer during the season and
he was with this hot blonde and I looked
at Joe and I looked at her and I looked
back at him and I'm like holy [ __ ] this
doesn't add up and I said I just
realized to Joe West this is eight
inches
nuts he walks out from behind the plate
in July I walk up I walk up to change
baseball because I gotta talk to him
I said he hands me the ball go Joe what
the [ __ ] he goes that Ball's about eight
inches outside boy he remembered exactly
and I'm like he got him back
[Laughter]
he never forgotten no you can say that
now because he retired which is cool
like some people had come back so I have
this guy to thank for that Marlins World
Series that I went to boy thank you Joe
West huh so anyways Kurt thanks for
coming out this was this was fantastic
appreciate you time uh we will
definitely have you back are we back on
again this morning we're back tomorrow
we're back on tomorrow okay sounds good
who's tomorrow uh Katie Hopkins Katie
Hopkins tomorrow we'll see you guys
there take care everybody bye-bye bye
bye-bye